[Music]
there is this
japanese buddhist monk who creates these
no such thing amazing relaxing
immersive sounds with his mouth and with
like
like uh dj devices
yeah yeah what does he do that that's
his mom's power
he he like merges like the the monk like
the buddhist chanting yeah with
him creating music um
hit him up and work with him because i i
was i was i was gathering all the media
for today
she's a new fan and i was i spent like
two hours listening to her [ __ ]
for a reason like my i'm being
transported to like
havana
[Applause]
1950s nirvana valhalla heaven like i was
just like
transported to like like wearing like
yeah so i'll play i'll play a clip right
now so this video i'm about to play that
went viral and then that's how he
started getting international attention
because
before then he had only had a japanese
audience but now
his japanese fellow among friends makes
makes about 20
of his audience now wow the world that
looks like like liking him
yep that's good because normal buddhist
chanting is so boring
oh my god it's the same [ __ ] over and
over
yeah oh damn all right machines and [ __ ]
full blast
full blast yes and reminder to not move
your heads
when we're viewing videos but i might
groove too too much
though well i'll keep it still i'll
still groove
with your like just the shoulders blink
just groove with your intestines
like an apple commercial for buddhism
yeah oh yeah i kept this part in there
just to have the respects to the
religion
he's a beatboxer that's what i said with
his mouth
and then all dj instruments
[Music]
whoa
yeah he does these live looping kind of
videos
damn jeremy after this yeah it's crazy
dude
right now yeah do it right now wow
look at the biting of the bottom lip
there dude
wow
i need to join forces with my brother
hey japanese brother
that's tight dude
like this when i was a kid i know right
i know if i was a kid i would be so much
more buddhist
yeah honestly i probably would why can't
religions like stay
cool like this imagine you go to that
temple and [ __ ] hacienda heights
and when you go in the [ __ ] monk has
a [ __ ]
you're like rocking the crap yeah just
[ __ ] lights and lasers
you know that giant siddhartha that's
like lying down the huge booth
but just like headphones like he has one
headphones
i know he fights i don't know how he djs
but i know this shirt
yeah he has one
yeah exactly damn
you're all [ __ ] brave and he goes we
are going to have a vegetarian lunch
at 12 o'clock everybody please go to the
hall yeah
put your hands together these are like
this but they got microphones in them
just microphones everywhere only i had
the one with like [ __ ] 10 000 arms in
the back
all mics and [ __ ]
that's dope yeah oh why is this guy so
cool
so he's 37 years old and he's based in
tokyo
and they give a little insight in his
background so he played guitar since he
was a teenager he became a beatboxer in
his early 20s
and that's when he bought his first boss
loop station
in 2009 and he started combining
beatboxing with
layers of vocals and and then he ended
up like traveling around the world
be like being kind of a a street
performer
and so he was able to make a living like
that but then 2015
is when he got ordained as a monk and he
followed his father in his father's
footsteps
and so he kind of like left music for a
while and
but he missed music so he was like you
know what like i really miss
making music but now i'm a monk i really
want to find a way to merge it
and that's when he started doing these
live looping videos
and but he's saying like music is it's
more than a hobby but it's not my main
thing
so he's still really focused on his
religion
i got my chance i got to do guys this is
a side gig
i wonder if the other monks were like
shut the [ __ ] up
shut the [ __ ] up on saturdays at the
temple people
are just regularly playing but when he
comes on at like 11 a.m everybody's like
you gotta do it from this side go
sideways yeah
that looks crazy
can you imagine the purists that are
against this [ __ ] though i bet they're
all like that man this is not boot is a
man
but they're tapping their feet while man
this is not right
their intestines are going like crazy
they're actually dancing
let me get this on sunday though yeah so
this video
or like this performance is called heart
sutra
oh it's tight it was uploaded a couple
of months ago and that's when it went
viral and so he was saying
quote in that video i made a big
decision because i wore a very formal
robe
it's the robe we wear when we do a
funeral it was during a serious period
for the coronavirus
the reaction really motivated me to
continue with this i'd like to do it at
a funeral in the future if people
will accept this kind of thing yeah so
in japan you get married shinto and then
you get buried buddhist
oh what oh so it's kind of like
both religions are a part of it i see
i know i've asked this in the past and i
know you've explained but i didn't
cement in my brain but what's the
difference between the religions oh
shinto is like completely different
well shinto is um the national religion
or the japanese religion it's like the
native one right
yeah it evolved from the the more of the
ancient
like it's kind of native
like they believe that there's a god in
everything
like in nature in like sometimes even
you know a rock
or like a you know like like a wind or
whatever just
all these things have energy or nature
life force life force yeah it's called
gods
is that what most of the temples in
japan are like are they
like shinto temples are they like
buddhist temples
uh it's difficult to tell because i i
grew up christian
but you can if you grew up there you
know which ones are like the
the red the red tory gates those are
shinto right those are gate realms the
gates
that's like you're entering into a
spiritual place or god's home
so those red gates that's what it
signifies so when you walk into one of
those it's like you're going into a
special sacred space
so it's kind of like if you think of the
native religions of the world like
there's like
you know certain burial grounds or like
there's like sacred spaces
like it's it's almost identical it's
just that they took it to the next level
and they structured it they don't have
that much scripture
but it's kind of like there's not much
doctrine
yeah like it's more like energies and
like spirits and things like that
and then there's like a million gods and
ghosts and whatever
yeah but it's very prevalent in japanese
culture like entertainment and like
video games and movies and stuff like
that yeah yeah you like recognize it
formally at shinto or not
like the whole final fantasy thing the
whole life force everything about
yeah that makes a lot like if you think
about all the anime like
totoro or like you know it's like or
spirited away
there's a lot if you get it you'll get
all the the
the spirits in the spirited away thing
you know the reason why
it's mary shinto funeral buddhist
because i don't know if shinto has a
funeral
system yeah i don't know well there is
afterlife because you have festivals
and then people like your ancestors come
or whatever
but buddhism doesn't conflict with
shintoism you could be both it's not
like christianity where there's only
one religion it's kind of like chinese
taoism
and buddhism can co-exist so it's
just yeah i think that it can integrate
and you can be both
cool yeah but buddhism it's you know
buddhism it's com it comes from what
india and and it traveled through china
yeah
so yeah so i don't know i really enjoyed
his music too but like how he does this
thing is like live looping right so
towards the end
he's like chanting and in japanese
do you have any parts of his uh the
final product
where he's chanting no i didn't want to
grab it i'll check that out later today
yeah sorry there's there's some dope
[ __ ] on his channel though
i like went through his entire catalog
pretty much and like there's certain
videos where he almost does like a house
beat like like
yeah like he does different types of
like electronics he calls it temple
[Laughter]
that'd be so cool there was more artists
that come out with things like this too
like more monks because what's tight is
since i grew up crazy buddhist
um what all the scriptures are actually
written uh like in sanskrit or like old
school indian
so um even the stuff that i chanted as a
kid
it's just the chinese phonetic version
of the original scriptures so even when
it's not translated
yeah so it's just the phonetic version
of it so if i go to japan if i go to
korea i could recognize it immediately
because they just do they say the same
thing they'd say their same theme but
because it's just all
sounds to them and so i wanted to hear
what it sounded like
oh like there's that one chant it's like
um
or whatever yeah it sounds like that
yeah yeah yeah yeah i think vietnamese
people but we made up our own
yeah it's still the same though are
those are those actual words
or they're just sounds so that one's
words you're you're chanting the names
you're actually saying words
which is uh so in english should be like
namo amitabha buddha but every
language has their own version yeah i
think this is sick because there's
always been like christian rock
but buddhist we don't got our own [ __ ]
we got house music we can just listen
now we got buddhist edm buddha cdm
yeah yo have you seen these monks
um i think it's in indonesia right but i
think it's called like the monkey chat
but there's like a
a hundred of them and then it's like
it's
i don't know yeah i think it's called
the monkey chat like no [ __ ]
but they're like
it's [ __ ] crazy that must be sick to
be there yeah
you feel like this stuff is really
powerful yeah
i went to a japanese wedding and it was
a buddhist wedding
and when everyone was in sync
really really chanting like honestly
this the spiritual presence of having
everybody being so
in sync with chanting is like
overwhelmingly powerful
you feel the weight and you hear like 12
different harmonies it sounds [ __ ]
crazy yeah
i've never experienced that but i think
the closest thing that i can like
relate to it with my own experience was
did you guys ever see midsummer
yeah maybe so you know the part where
she's crying oh my gosh
like so there's this part where she's
like sobbing and everybody's like
stopping like they're crying with her
like it's like a group of women and
they're like literally like
like wailing the same way she is they're
releasing and that was so powerful to me
where like i
felt it where i was like even though i'm
not in the room and like whatever
you guys seen this movie oh [ __ ] read
it because it just
seemed too crazy is it that cult thing
yeah yeah
europe or reading or whatever yeah
there's some scenes where you're just
like
what the [ __ ] did i just watch well
group prayer
just group everything that when you
collectively do an energy it's just a
crazy experience though yeah i really
recommend that movie and it is
wild but explicit warning but yeah to me
it really left me feeling really nice
like and you want to join a cult now
no not a cult like it made me feel like
that was a happy ending like
right anthony she she found a family
like i don't know i really liked it i
had to read the synopsis on wikipedia
and i was like i can never watch this
movie
no no you have to watch it i'm watching
it you have to watch it now to
understand her because i don't
understand
i'm watching it we walked out with a
very different very different
like that was horrendous and i'm like
that was so i understand where you're
coming from
but i don't know about nice like you
should feel nice after that yeah i just
thought it was beautiful that's it
it was like [ __ ] cults are beautiful
there's one called jamalia that's really
beautiful
[Music]
oh